Okay, let's get into audience questions for
the week.
I genuinely love this first question I have,
I'll have to say about it.
Hey David.
What, what
wastes of money are you shocked people still
fall for?
Um, I, there's like a big one which I'm going
to lead up to, but a couple of small things
are, I am always surprised when people buy
insurance on relatively small purchases.
And I understand the, um, idea that if it's
something very expensive, uh, you actually
may suffer a hardship if it breaks and you
have to fix it or replace it.
I can understand getting an insurance policy
replacement plan, extended warranty or whatever,
but particularly as someone who worked at
circuit city and sold a lot of these, uh,
inexpensive and service plans and stuff like
that, it really doesn't make sense on small
purchases.
And I don't know why anybody you continues
to buy it.
And the way I, I now don't get insurance on
anything, no service plans, no warranties,
any of that stuff.
And the calculation I've made is that all
of the stuff I never got insurance on and
it never broke.
That's thousands upon thousands of dollars
in insurance dollars that I never spent.
So I'm so far ahead at this point that I feel
like I'm properly kind of like self insured
health insurance.
Of course I have, um, you know, home insurance,
I think I have to have it, but I have that.
But, um, insurance plans on really inexpensive
items I think are a waste of money in general.
Stuff that people don't use and don't cancel.
I'm still surprised at the number of people
of friends I have who say I really got to
cancel that, a credit monitoring thing or
whatever.
I never look at it.
I don't even know what my access code is,
but I just keep paying the 25 bucks a month.
You got to cancel that stuff.
That is a stunning waste of money to me.
But the really, the big one that shocks me,
how are people still falling for pyramid schemes?
And as it has been more friendly, uh, uh,
more sort of appealingly renamed multilevel
marketing.
I don't know how people still fall for it.
The number of people I'm friends with on Facebook
that are doing a whole bunch of these multilevel
marketing things, uh, is, is absolutely shocking
to me.
And whenever it comes up in sort of social
settings, I, I, I'm not trying to have huge
conflicts with people in my personal life.
So I will often be very, very polite and actually
say, Oh, uh, eh, how many sales have you actually
made?
And they'll say, well, you know, for now I
really only purchased my supply of stuff.
Um, so that I have demos and I've only made
like a sailor too.
And I say, Oh, okay.
Um, so, but now you have all that stuff that
you can sell over the next few months.
And they'll say, well, actually, you're in
order to remain as a reseller, you actually
have to place an order every month.
And then I say, oh, so every month you actually
have more stuff you have to buy regardless
of whether you're making any sales.
And they say, yeah, you do, but I'm building
my business and all this stuff.
It's stunning, stunning to me that people
are still falling for that stuff.
And I think I get one aspect of it, which
is wages have been stagnant for however long
they've been stagnant.
Um, people are looking to make some extra
money.
People want autonomy.
So all of these MLMs and pyramid schemes are
designed to prey upon people who say, Hey,
okay, I have a job and I don't want to leave
that job, but I would like a little extra
money.
I would like to build my own business and
be my own boss and work on my own time.
And uh, that's why people fall for it because
it is appealing.
It is actually appealing.
Um, but it is so, so pernicious.
And of course the number of people who even
make back their initial investment is relatively
small.
Nevermind.
You know, the number of people, whoever make
over $1,000 period with any of these things
in profit is so astronomically small and you're
always told about the success stories don't
fall for it.
Don't fall for it.
There is a, there are endless resources online
about all of the companies that are Mlms and
pyramid schemes.
You'll notice, I haven't named any of them
in this segment because a lot of those companies
are very, very litigious and I'm not interested
in that.
But please stop.
And this is also to my friends.
Please, please stop.
You're falling for scams and um, it just get
focused on improving yourself.
Start a real small business if that's what
you're interested in doing.
Look at just working a little more or developing
your skills so that you can get a promotion.
I think that those are much better uses of
time and money than participating in these
MLM nonsense schemes.